bonsoir vous êtes très intimidant
figurez vous qu'il n'ya pas si longtemps
très récemment même je ne savais pas du
tout ce que j'allais vous dire alors bon
j'avais quand même des idées je savais
de quoi j'avais envie de vous parler
mais entre l'excitation et angoisse
aussi les idées se mélangeaient j'étais
un peu perdue bref je me suis dit c'est
le moment de passer à l'action
alors comme toute femme aussi courageuse
aussi forte et aussi indépendante que je
le suis j'ai pris la bonne décision
je suis rentré chez mon papa et ma maman
et j'ai bien fait puisque une fois
arrivé je me suis rappelé de ce
merveilleux lieu qu'est la cuisine de ma
mère pour moi la cuisine de ma mère
c'est un lieu magique féerique
c'est un lieu où tout est rangé et
propre ordonné alors moi je n'ai pas du
tout hérité de ce don pour ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une harmonie logique
pas du tout j'ai longtemps été grondée
longuement puisque je ne mangeais pas ma
chambre
et puis un jour j'ai enfin fini par
comprendre ce jour là quand ma mère est
entrée dans ma chambre furax et qu'elle
m'a dit mais c'est pas possible
mais on voit même pas le sol mais
comment tu fais pour dire trouver je lui
ai dit tête à tête
c'est quand même pas ma faute c'est vous
qui m'avez fait j'y suis pour rien moi
on n'a jamais éduqué comme ça yolande à
leur maman toi peut-être mais descend
dans le garage et va jeter un coup
d'oeil à l'établi de papa est là tu vas
comprendre d'où vient mon don pour le
bordel organisé
je vous avoue que ce souvenir m'a
rappelé combien il est difficile de
maîtriser ce que l'on transmet surtout
d'une génération à une autre
chaque parent veut le meilleur pour son
enfant
moi mes parents ils voulaient que je
sois en bonne santé que je fasse du
sport que je nourrisse bien mon corps
est aussi une activité culturelle pour
à nourrir mon esprit je sois
suffisamment dynamique pour pouvoir
crapahuter avec eux le week end dans la
nature pendant leur marche dans le pilat
alors comment vous dire moi j'ai une
carte de fidélité au mcdo je prends
toujours les escalators
même quand les escaliers sont
entièrement vide je fume et quant à mon
amour pour la nature
sachez que je n'aime rien plus que les
petites bottines à paillettes que j'ai
acheté l'hiver dernier alors comment
cela est-il possible
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
réellement transmettre en tant que
parent comment est ce qu'on est sûr que
les valeurs qui nous sont chères
on arrive à les transmettre à nos
enfants certains parlent d'une question
de génération ah le fameux conflit
générationnel
il est même arrivé en entreprise
les managers se retrouvent bouche bée
face à des jeunes qu'ils ne comprennent
pas qu'il est impossible de contenter
alors que clairement avec un petit peu
de découpe et de bienveillance ont
résolu est peut-être le problème
mais comment est ce qu'on fait mesdames
et messieurs j'aimerais que ce soir on
considère s'il vous plaît que le conflit
intergénérationnel n'existe pas nous ne
sommes pas en désaccord les uns avec les
autres
chaque génération a vécu jusqu'à preuve
du contraire sont propres traumatismes
ce qui a créé certes des petits conflits
avec la précédente est la suivante
bon je vous explique on va prendre un
schéma simple et caricatural nos grands
parents ont connu la guerre bîmes
traumatisme ils ont donc voulu que leurs
enfants ne manquent de rien ils ont
voulu leur transmettre du confort et ces
enfants là mes parents ont eu du mal
avec ce manque d'affection
quoi pas de communication émotionnelle
bim traumatisme alors ils ont voulu
donner le meilleur et tout l'amour qu'il
possédait à leurs enfants leurs enfants
qui sont la prunelle de leurs yeux les
chérir en faire des enfants rois
et quand enfin ces enfants là new
generation brignoles on se réveille et
on se rend compte que la vie n'est pas
un film de walt disney bîmes traumatisme
alors chaque génération vous voyez là ça
se répète chaque génération connaît ses
propres difficultés par rapport à son
environnement
en fait on a tous les mêmes problèmes on
a tous peur de l'inconnu on se pose tous
des questions et on avance tous sans
vraiment savoir exactement comment faire
et ce conflit pourquoi est ce qu'on
appelle conflit alors que peut-être le
problème est tout simplement un problème
de communication et j'entends par
communication l'écoutent la
compréhension et la tolérance avec une
vraie écoute avec une bonne
communication
chaque génération de votre être capable
de comprendre l'autre et puis ne vous
inquiétez pas on arrive toujours à
transmettre de bonnes choses j'en
reviens à ma mère qui à chaque fin de
journée
prenez le temps de s'asseoir avec moi
pour prendre le goûter et écouté toutes
mes histoires
oui foot oui elle écoutait l'histoire de
camille qui avait triché à la corde à
sauter toute la journée
et croyez-moi quand on a 5 ans voir un
adulte qui s'intéressent à ce problème
là ça compte
et chaque soir pendant goûter ma mère me
transmettait un petit peu de sa capacité
d écoute
j'aimerais conclure en vous remettant
deux mots est-ce que c'est ces deux mots
là que je voulais vous transmettre ce
soir écoute et bienveillance
merci
[Applaudissements]